we bumped into a Spanish Rescue Team on
the road
so we decided to follow them
and we spend a lot of time in the car
because these Mountain Villages are so
remote
we've been driving for about an hour now
remember we've stopped on the side of
the road for a while now with the rescue
teams that we uh we've been following
it's not really clear why
this helicopter has just come into land
first it uh unloaded eight supplies and
then they carried a person on the
stretcher not fair
what their situation was but uh
helicopter now
heading off such a crucial Lifeline to
these remote villagers
so a lot of people have come out to
watch the helicopter and these are
nurses hi do you work here yes
yes
the nurses how many are you four for all
of uh
Village
just the four of you yeah how has it
been what have you seen since you've
been working here
the situation with the people
the most people are still scared
specific children they have a nightmares
the needs of this population they need
not all not just medicines but also they
need the psychologists psychology water
and medicines for fever especially for
children and
support for mental health what are the
main challenges do you remember a moment
that was the most
that you remember the most we need to be
strong to so yes to help them
we need to you have to yes we have to be
strong even if we feel like yes
you girls are amazing honestly we can
show you where are they stay in
foreign
these women tell us they need running
water clothes blankets food toilets
so they are thinking a lot about the
future how to rebuild yes and they want
to know
how
how and well
what to do Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera
adasil in Morocco's Atlas Mountains